do you know what the uh the caffeine
pills were trivia what's that what do
you think they were red
oh no those yeah but no what what did we
you can you can't oh oh yeah
no no and mike and ikes are big oh
how silly
so these are little oh ticky tacks ticky
tacks
cinnamon ticky tac that's not the right
answer uh no
no you just call me an it came
out didn't it it kind of came out it's
like that's not the right answer
actually a game show host it'd be
awesome
you could have slipped it real good yeah
yeah they were taken out no they were
not tic tacs what were they they were
red hots red hots so
drinking game saved by the bell trivia
you will never lose
i'm sure that comes up every time
i just need to learn your dad's name hey
steve steve i don't know steve morris
derek
they just went like this like obviously
uh
what was the name of the gang that zach
betrayed uh screech for to get the red
jacket
see i never even knew that i i
thought i'd betrayed screech throughout
the whole entire
six year run you did i really was a
terrible friend you were so i betrayed
them even more for a red jacket
you know honestly honestly i have that
red jacket hanging up in my house i'm
not kidding you do not i do
you're still a rygma
no but i got the answer oh yeah
really it was a it was called the rigmas
rigmas together forever forever was that
was that on the college years though no
that was like back when you really had a
big poof
big plot a lot of work went into that
before you started slicking the sides
that wasn't slick i shaved it i was like
oh yeah and then you shave robin van
winkle
i could do this for a while
do you know how i got that whole hair
like that tell me
do you know back in like the uh i think
it was the 80s not early 90s sure uh we
used to have these visors that were
plastic and they were like neon you guys
remember these they didn't they didn't
wrap around your head because if they
wrapped around your head they would
leave an indent so they're like these
plastic viruses so from my drive from my
house to the set i would put in like you
know the gel and stuff like that and
then i would put on the visor
my hair is wet but i put on the visor
and i would drive and i would kind of
leave the window a little open and it
would kind of like you know the air from
there but by the time i got to the set
it'd be dry and then i take the visor
carefully off
and then i had that perfect crest of a
wave
mark
yeah
i know i should rap i have to tell you
this
we can do this all day i know i know
this is a true story though this is
something i told jp the segment producer
and i told him that there was a joke
that ac said to you something like this
from the kid who does his hair out the
bus window yeah and as a kid watching it
i went that's how he does it
and that was how you did it
you